[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله معكم محمد زيمز
ونستعرض معا ابرز اخبار الاسبوع الماضي
بايجاز وفي نشرتنا مقتل مؤسسي شركه
تيفاجنر الاحتجاجات تعود الى سوريا هل نرى
محمد صلاح في الدوري السعودي بالاضافه الى
اخبار اخرى نتابعها معا
لنبدا مع خبر مقتل قائد مجموعه فاجنر
العسكريه بعد تحطم الطائراته في مقاطعه
حيث ادى الحادث الى مقتدى عشره اشخاص
كانوا على متنها بينهم
الذي نعاه الرئيس بوتين وقال انه عرفه منذ
زمن طويل لكنه ذكر انه ارتكب اخطاء جسيمه
في حياته تحطم الطائره جاء بعد شهرين على
محاوله التمرد التي قادها بريجوجل وزحفت
خلالها مجموعه من قوه فاجنر الى موسكو في
محاوله لطاحه بالقياده العسكريه للبلاد في
وقت اثيرت فيه تكهنات كثيره في الاوساط
الغربيه بشان احتمال ضلوع الكرملين في
مقتله لكن روسيا نفت ذلك تفاعلات واسعه
شهدتها منصات التواصل حول هذا الخبر لنرى
بعض التعليقات
خليل العمري يقول ما فعلته فاجنر كان طعنه
في الكبرياء الروسي وما كان لزعيمها ان
يتوقع انه على قيد الحياه بعدما فعل
والان مع احمد عياش الذي يقول سقوط
الطائره ربما كان مجرد حادث او تم قصفها
بالخطا وقد يكون الغرب هو الذي فخاخها في
محاوله لتحديد
ومنعها من التدخل في النيجر الى جنوب
افريقيا حيث اختتمت مجموعه بريكس قمتها
التي استمرت ثلاثه ايام بالموافقه على
توسعه غير مسبوقه بدعوتها لست دول جديده
لعضويتها هي الارجنتين ومصر واثيوبيا
وايران والسعوديه والامارات التي رحبت كل
منها بهذه الدعوه في حين اكدت مجموعه
بريكس في بيانها الختامي على السعي لنظام
عالمي متعدد والتخلص من هيمنه الدولار اذا
حديث عن التخلص من هيمنه الدولار في
الاقتصادي العالمي ينضم الي الزميل نديم
الملاح مذيع النشره الاقتصاديه في الجزيره
مرحبا نديم يا مرحبا
نديم ما واقعيه ذلك حاليا اذا نضعها في
الوقت الراهن صعب جدا الان اطلاق هذه
العمله لان الدولار كعمله معظم التجاره
العالميه يتم تداول عبر هذا ولكنها ربما
تكون خطوه مستقبليه الان اهدافها سياسيه
ولكن على المدى البعيد ربما تعكس التغيرات
الاقتصاديه التي سوف تحصل في العالم مثل
متوقع في 2030 ان يكون الاقتصاد الصيني ان
يتجاوز الاقتصاد الامريكي فكل ذلك مرتبط
بمدى جديه تلك الدول وحجم الدول التي سوف
تنضم الى الى هذا التجمع والتكتل خاصه
الدول ذات الثقل الاقتصادي التي هناك حجم
تبادلات كبيره بينها وبين اعضائها لكي يتم
انه يكون لها ثقل هذه العمله شكرا
الى سوريا التي تشهد احتجاجات شعبيه غاضبه
احتجاجا على ترد الاوضاع الاقتصاديه ما
لبثت ان حملت مطالب برحيل الرئيس السوري
بشر الاسد الذي حمله الظاهرون مسؤوليه
تدهري الوضع المعيشي في البلاد الاحتجاجات
انطلقت قبل ايام في محافظه السويداء قبل
ان تنتقل الى مناطق عده خاضعه لسيطره
النظاميه سوري اذا نطاق الاحتجاجات
التاسعه ولكن ما افق هذه الاحتجاجات هذا
ما اسال عنه الزميل المنتصر ابو نبوت يا
مرحبا منتصر هل فعليا ثمه اي ارضيه لتحرك
شعبي او سحب محمد بالتاكيد هناك ارضيه
لهذه الاحتجاجات هي خرجت في الاساس
للاحتجاج على ترد الاوضاع المعيشيه
والاوضاع الاقتصاديه في سوريا اتسعت
لتطالب باسقاط النظام السوري ما دامت
الاوضاع المعيشيه سيئه في سوريا فهذه
الاحتجاجات سوف تستمر وسوف تخرج مزيد من
المناطق خصوصا في الحاضنه الشعبيه لنظام
السوري يتحدثون عن الساحل السوري ليس فقط
عن محافظه السويداء بالاضافه الى درعه
والاضافه الى حلب جميع هذه المناطق شهدت
احتجاجات وشهدت تعالي الاصوات التي تطالب
بتغيير الوضع الحالي ما بين اسقاط النظام
وما بين المطالبه بتحسين الوضع المعيشي
شكرا جزيلا منتصر يعطيك الف عافيه الان
الى خبر اخر يتعلق بالقمر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
خطوه ادخلت الهند التاريخ اذ هبطت مركبتها
الفضائيه تشندريان ثلاثه بنجاح على القطب
الجنوبي للقمر غير المستكشف كثيرا والذي
يعتقد انه مصدر محتمل للمياه والاكسجين
وهو ما يشكل سابقه عالميه في برنامج فضائي
ومحطه تاريخيه لدوله من اكثر بلدان العالم
تعدادا للسكان والتي انضمت الى نادي الدول
القليله التي نجحت في الهبوط على القمر
بدات اليابان الاسبوع الماضي في تصريف
المياه المعالجه من محطه الطاقه النوويه
المتضرره في بوكو شيما في المحيط الهادئ
وهو ما اثار احتجاج الصين التي عرضت بشده
اعلن اليابان وشددت على ان مياهها الصرف
المشعه تمثل مشكله كبيره فيما يتعلق
بسلامه النوويه كما تظاهر مئات الاشخاص في
اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه للمطالبه
بالتراجع عن هذه الخطوه بينما قال مسؤول
في كوريا الشماليه ان اطلاق المياه
المعالجه سيكون له تاثير ضار وقاتل على
حياه البشر والامن والبيئه وسطها اسرائيل
طوكيو على انها امنه لا تزال هذه العمليه
تثير جدلا واسعا وقلقا دوليا في التعليق
الاول تجدون تقريرا يشرح تفاصيل اكثر عن
هذه العمليه وايضا عن تاثيراتها شائعات
بشان قرب انتقال محمد صلاح الى الدوري
السعودي حيث تحدثت التقارير اعلاميه عن
موافقه النجم المصري الانتقال الى نادي
الاتحاد السعودي في صفقه انقلاب انها قد
تضاهي او ربما تتجاوز ما حصل عليه كل من
رونالدو ونيمار للانضمام الى النصر
والهلال من جهته نفى مدرب ليفربول هذا
الخبر واشار انه لا نيه للنادي للتخلي عن
صلاح حاليا كنا قد سالناكم عن رايكم حول
احتماليه انتقال محمد صلاح الى الدوري
السعودي
41% منكم قالوا نعم بين ما تسعه وخمسون في
المئه قالوا لا مثل ما يقال الخبر بفلوس
بكره ببلاش نلتقي الاسبوع المقبل في ايجاز
اسبوعي اخر حينما كنتم ضبط اوقاتكم بكل
خير
[موسيقى]